und dann können sie demonstrieren vor
dem Rathaus in Hannover die steigenden
Gaspreise schüren Angst und Ärger
besonders groß ist die Wut bei den
Bäckereien eine traditionsbranche probt
den Aufstand sie fühlen sich nicht mehr
ernst genommen mit ihren Zukunftssorgen
also im Moment muss ganz ehrlich sein
ich trage das mit nach Hause ich habe
Existenzängste wir haben verdoppelte
Rohstoffpreise die Energiepreise ich
habe mit meinen Lieferanten gesprochen
Energieanbieter der hat mir gesagt nach
stand heute müsste sich der Preis für
sieben bis vor neunfachen das wären
Mehrkosten für mein Betrieb von ca
100-250.000 bis 200.000 Euro also ich
kann schließen das kann ich natürlich
nicht wuppen und natürlich liebe euch
man auch mit den Supermarkt Brötchen
weil sie einfach günstig sind aber bis
jetzt können die Bäcker noch mit ihrer
Qualität überzeugen mit dem mit dem
Handwerk und dann ist man immer noch
bereit mehr auszugeben weil man auch
etwas anderes bekommt ein eine
Handwerkskunst an das Boot schmeckt
einfach anders aber
keiner gerade jeder muss ja seine
Energiekosten auch bezahlen und dann
irgendwann ist es aber Schluss dann kann
jemand nicht mehr für ein Brot mehr als
fünf sechs sieben acht Euro ausgeben
dann ist Schluss und dann werden alle
nur noch in die Discounter gehen und das
heißt für künne und für andere hier dich
alle auch gut kenne für die geht dann
der Ofen aus im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes weil auch der Kunde bei dem wird
auch irgendwann diese Energiekrise
ankommen der wird dann auch nicht mehr
das Geld haben und der wird vielleicht
auch zum Discounter gehen oder sonst was
weil er sich einfach das Handwerk
Brötchen nicht mehr leisten kann weil
wir die weil wir diese laufenden Kosten
immer mehr werden ob es Rohstoffe sind
Energie oder sonst was können wir
einfach irgendwann nicht mehr umlegen
dann müssen wir ein Brötchen bald ein
Euro kosten und Kilo Brot 8 bis 10 Euro
die Zutaten sind teurer geworden Zucker
und mehlpreise haben sich fast
verdoppelt dazu die steigenden
Energiekosten
zu meisternamen wir haben alle gedacht
nach Corona nach Corona ist das alles
nicht mehr zu toppen und jetzt kriegen
wir noch solche Brocken vor die Füße
geschmissen das ist eine Herausforderung
im Moment und auch gerade nach der
langen coronazeit die auch für meine
Mitarbeiter nicht ganz so einfach war
die Leute noch zu motivieren mit Freude
zur Arbeit zu gehen und Spaß dabei zu
haben ist ja außer Frage ist dass man um
die Existenz mittlerweile kämpft und es
kommt auch bei meinem Mitarbeitern
Kollegen mittlerweile an die sich Sorgen
machen Sie sich überlegen was wird in
der Zukunft ich habe auch Mitarbeiter
seit 20 Jahren mittlerweile bei mir im
Unternehmen zusammenarbeiten und auch
gerne bei mir in Rente gehen würden und
zusammen eventuell und das eventuell
jetzt gefährdet ist durch die aktuelle
Lage der wir uns befinden und das
schlimme ist dabei dass man gefühlt
unverschuldet und diese Lage geraten ist
und wie so ein Passagier dabei sitzt und
nicht viel tun kann auch wenn ich so
richtig dass diese Aktion so wie sie
hier ist stattfindet und wir und unser
Berg auf uns aufmerksam machen einfach
auf das ganz wichtig dass uns man dass
man uns nicht allein lässt dass man uns
hilft
lautstark protestieren sie weiter auf
den Straßen
ihre Botschaft soll überall gehört
werden bevor der Ofen endgültig ausgeht